now this question here if you were to
get something like this we're definitely
being towards the end of the paper if
not the very end of the paper still
don't want as a two-unit student to unit
students will get this kind of question
exactly in the HSC if they're unlucky so
I'm just going to show you quickly how I
would do this if you don't have any
particular interest in this right now
that's fine you went quietly and your
trips nice but maybe some of you are
looking this and thinking I don't know
how I would do that so mush it all of
you down also I think there are politics
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you the quick version so I may not
explain that all every individual step
along the way because I have shown you
how to do some of these before
so if you want that didn't go back to
you or come and hassle me another time
what area do you want to work on
something else that's totally fine just
do it
can I just give a short hands just so I
don't hit my eye contact who's watching
this okay most I think you hear them
he's alone no do it I'm going to
approach this as a graph figure out this
is a graph I'm gonna just do a rough
sketch of it and I want to know when the
graph is below 1/2 wherever that happens
to be ok so my first job is let's graph
this thing I am going to think of it as
this absolute value plus this absolute
value now do you remember I gave you
something like this in the quiz that you
just did right you know what this looks
like and if you slap an absolute value
sign on it but negative at the front
then instead of being all above the
x-axis you're going to be all below the
x-axis and that's exactly what this is
okay so much how quickly you can grab
this once you sort of get the hang of
what
he's my axes okay absolute value of X
minus one that's been shifted this is
this right but it's been shifted one
unit to DA right so I'm just going to
quickly draw left that's all the detail
that I need this guy is two things
number one I'm going to shift him to the
left two units so bit further than that
and then I'm gonna flip them upside down
okay so that's one unit so I guess just
to keep the scale one two and then down
and there I go okay now these two things
I need to add them okay really easy
watch zero plus whatever is whatever I
don't even know where it is now it
doesn't matter to me okay I just want
the general picture zero plus whatever
is whatever okay have a look at the
outsides see how they've got the same
radiant but in opposite directions so
when you add them they're going to
cancel out okay so this is just going to
be a horizontal line over there
same thing happens over here for the
opposite reason horizontal why and guess
what when you add straight lines no
matter which way they're going you're
going to get more straight lines I'm not
there's the graph okay so now I've got
this picture over here I want to know
when is it less than but below
uh-huh okay so now I need to be a little
more careful of that my scale I'm gonna
say where's a hut well it's gotta be
somewhere what did I say that was this
is the absolute value of X minus one so
this is one right here so 1/2 is roughly
there okay you're right with that so
this is y equals 1/2 clearly I can
already see if the pus that I'm
interested in these guys down here do
you agree with that that's all the stuff
below so really the last piece of
information is what on earth is that
done that's all that matters to me
okay so I look and I see which of the
branches are going to be combined to
give me this line so I can find a point
of intersection you'll have a look at
the branches I haven't labeled them but
can you see what they are clearly this
one must be y equals 1 minus X you're
great you see how it's going down
this one over here must by the same
logic being 2 minus X do you agree now
sorry minus 2 minus X does that make
sense
do you see where I've got that from it's
got to be the one sloping down copy X
plus 2 must be the negative version so
in order to get the equation of this
mental middle branch okay I'm just going
to add this and this that's y equals
minus 2x which accounts for the
steepness of it if you see how the
middle part is steep plus minus minus 1
that's 1
yes which by the way because of the
awesomeness of my graph you can see like
he pretty much does hit the axis at
negative 1 right and that was you saw
how roughly and quickly I did that okay
so this is the equation of that little
bit I just need to know when it
intersects with 1/2 so can you tell me
what to do
okay I'll add one to both sides which is
going to make this three on two and it
leaves their negative two x over there
now what I would divide both sides by
negative two which I believe gives me
negative three waters are you happy with
that does it look like it should be
negative three quarters yeah not bad
okay so if that is negative three
quarters right that's the boundary value
am I going to the left or am I going to
the right I'm going to the right because
look these are the bits that up below
the Green Line so X is if it's to the
right greater than negative 3/4 mm okay
question this is my working and I would
argue if you think about I mean I can do
this whole thing algebraically there are
three cases to this one two three you
can lay all of the math you can get
exactly the same answer out I would
argue that the working of this is a
whole lot clearer than about 15 lines in
algebra that will still achieve the same
answer but why don't gotta read through
all those in like what's going on where
is it
it speaks for itself okay so this amount
of working is purpose generating